gemeinsam packen sie an um die schäden
der flut zu beseitigen
die solidarität ist groß in deutschland
trotz der chorakademie kommen
freiwillige helfer aus dem ganzen land
in die überschwemmten gebiete ich hier
nach ahrweiler in rheinland pfalz
abstand halten maske tragen daran ist
gar nicht zu denken
man hat ja schon oft gehört dass co wird
einfach durch diese fluten weggespült
wurde
das würde er alles behindern und die
leute noch mehr frustrierend wenn sie
auch noch bei den arbeiten auf abstände
und so sachen achten müssen momentan
denkt glaube ich gar keine grad über
profit nach weil wir müssen erstmal
zusehen dass wir die leute die hier ihr
haus verloren viele haben gar nichts
mehr gar nix hier waren ex viele
existenzen die einfach weg sind
wohnungen die zeitgleich weg sind dann
wird es nur noch darum gekümmert dass
die leute irgendwie irgendwo unterkommt
in der notunterkunft stehen die betten
dicht an dicht
tagsüber leer aber die nacht verbringen
obdachlose anwohner und ihre helfer hier
auf engem raum zusammen
ein möglicher cupid hotspot aber das
infektionsrisiko beschäftigt die
menschen hier kaum
man merkt einfach denen geht es um leben
und tod die haben alles verloren
da ist rohner nicht das thema für diese
menschen und wir wollen uns auch nicht
zumuten dazu sehr einzugreifen weil die
leute sind traumatisiert von dem was sie
erlebt haben und da können oder stets
uns auch einfach nicht sozusagen jetzt
aber bitte
die aha regeln beachten
erst das unwetter mit den sturzfluten
und der massiven zerstörung und jetzt
wird befürchtet dass sich kurve tier
verstärkt ausbreitet
um dem vorzubeugen ist in ahrweiler eine
mobile test und im station angekommen
die infrastruktur wurde zerstört das
infomobil wird erstmal weiter zur
verfügung stehen
man muss auf eine sehr feinfühlige art
und weise der bevölkerung hier ein
bisschen nahebringen dass ihnen zwar
alles weggeschwommen ist aber
dummerweise dieses virus nicht knapp die
hälfte der deutschen ist inzwischen
vollständig geimpft aber die delta
variante ist auf dem vormarsch
die organisatoren hoffen dass viele das
impfangebot noch wahrnehmen
doch einige bewohner sind skeptisch ich
bin schon kämpft schon lange aber viele
leute die ich kenne die sind nicht die
ämter und wir haben jetzt ganz
persönlich warum sie nicht im finish
mails zu tun alles hier zum affen
kämpfen ist nicht wichtig wie das
in diesem chaos auch noch kobe zu
bekämpfen
eine herausforderung kaum zu bewältigen